for the past decade or more the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has dominated the box
office and pop culture as a whole but
sandwiched in between the MCU mega
blockbusters Captain Marvel and Avengers
endgame there's another little superhero
movie from the underdogs at DC Comics
and it's actually really awesome how
awesome well here's a spoiler filled
look at the four best and for worse
things about Shazam the films that the
DC extended universe have a well-earned
reputation for being dark grim and
gritty which a lot of audiences felt
weren't too much fun to watch there's a
lot of angst and moral ambivalence and
very little in the way of actual heroism
instead they seem to feature angry
people who clearly aren't getting enough
fiber in their diets so maybe the
biggest surprise about Shazam is that
it's not just funny it's also actually
fun from start to finish
director David F Sandberg mostly does a
great job keeping the tone upbeat and
energetic as team Billy Batson discovers
his incredible new powers it's true that
Aquaman also dared to have at least a
good time along the way but Billy's
exuberance at becoming a superhero is
something we haven't really seen before
and it's a welcome change compared to
the DCE use usual dark and violent fair
did you believe yeah on the other hand
while Shazam is mostly family-friendly
fun once in awhile it just sort of
forgets itself and beers off into the
realm of horror of course this makes
some sense considering that Sandberg is
best known for directing the acclaimed
horror hits lights out and Annabel
creation still the total shifts are
jarring one minute Billy and his foster
brother Freddy Freeman are clowning
around doing the floss and then the next
minute the evil dr. sivana is summoning
a horde of demons to literally eat
people's heads off oh snap you're like a
bad guy right these abrupt detours into
terror feel kinda out of place and
unnecessary luckily it doesn't happen
often but even a couple of times might
be a couple of times too many across the
board the stars of Shazam deliver and
then some Zachary Levi is the super
heroic adult form that young Billy takes
maintains a level of boyish wonder while
using his grown-up physicality to great
effect he also has a terrific rapport
with Jack Dillon grazer as Billy's
foster brother Freddie Freeman and
grazer similarly has excellent chemistry
with ash or angel who plays the younger
less mighty mortal version of Billy it's
hard enough for most movies to find even
one star that's right for any given part
but Shazam somehow nailed the casting
for its three biggest roles and the
movie is much better for it still not
every role comes off as well as it could
have and one area where the movie really
falls short is its villains that's not
actually a knock on actor Mark Strong
who plays the lead villain dr. thaddeus
sivana strong has a long history of
playing baddies and films and he's very
good at being very bad but unfortunately
while all the stuff with billy and
freddie feels fresh and new the scenes
with dr. sivana feel like they were
cobbled together from a list of boring
supervillain cliches plus his demonic
cgi helpers have boring designs the
coolest saying Shazam did with villains
was teasing mr. mind an evil genius worm
in the mid-credits scene we just wish he
had been the lead villain of this one
too at least that wouldn't have been
just more of the same when movie makers
don't respect the comics their films are
based on the result is always bad and
always disappointing just look at films
like Jonah Hex or even Man of Steel
which was controversial among longtime
comic book fans in that one many have
said that director Zack Snyder didn't
believe the concept of a pure hero like
Superman was relevant the impulse to
make comic book movies more serious
because the filmmakers want to be taken
seriously is never a good thing which is
why it's so great that Shazam actually
rebels and it's comic book origins the
filmmakers don't mind being goofy
because they know it's fine as long as
audiences are brought along for the ride
characters like mr. mind or silly but
they're exactly the kind of silly we've
been waiting for all along Shazam is
trying to do a lot of different things
it's got comedy it's got action it's got
a heartwarming family message at its
gooey center and it's a modern superhero
fable but while it does most of these
things pretty well trying to do them all
at once results in a movie going
experience that's kind of like trying to
eat a Chipotle burrito it's just over
stopped and that over ambition shows in
the film's runtime for a fast paced fun
movie
Shazaam isn't actually all that
fast-paced instead it runs a whopping
two hours and twelve minutes which is
maybe a half hour too long Shazaam is
really good but like the old saying goes
sometimes you can get too much of a good
thing
a little restraints would have been
better for the movie and better for your
bladder superpowers dude I don't even
know how to pee in this thing like all
good films Shazam is actually about
something more than simple superhero
fist fights at the heart of the film is
young Billy Batson and his quest to find
his family in the end he realizes his
true family was right in front of him
all along it's a great art made all the
better by the performances of the actors
who play his foster siblings especially
faith Herman as the precocious Darla
even better the twist ending where all
of his siblings are granted the powers
of the wizard Shazam is a great callback
to the comics scene Billy and his
siblings come together to fight crime
was a great surprise that delivered both
the action and the fields at the same
time about the only thing that could
have made the superhero family twist
even better was if we hadn't already
known it was coming
so who spoiled it for everyone no it
wasn't some paparazzi or gossip websites
instead it's the modern scourge of film
fans everywhere merchandise tie-ins yes
unfortunately images of the action
figures released months before the
film's April release spoiling the
surprise
hey toy companies next time could you
please keep it zipped until after the
movie is out check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]